[Applause]
hi vfs i am
loving all the costumes i love halloween
i love halloween week i love drew
scarymore
like the funnest pun of my name that's
ever been used i see
sia i see cat lady
i see sk like is that a scarecrow
is that oh i see a beautiful mother and
daughter oh i see a casey becker from
scream
i see a chicken lady oh my gosh
and a balloon up are you up
you're up i get it i see it oh
oh ghost face
ghost face what are you doing here
my goodness ghostface i can't talk to
you
i have a big show dr phil is here by the
way
dr phil how are you
oh i'm so glad well then you know what
let's just get right to it
we're going to take a look at your show
while you change out a ghost face look
for all that tape
you didn't come here to change you came
here to defend
no i want to change i haven't met a lot
of parents that bit their adult
child right you you've been in jt but
let me tell you why that was
wait okay you're so you're going to now
justify it yeah i just want to label
this
okay but i want to tell you something
apparent let me be sure i got this under
the right category
you know okay but let me tell you why he
had my head like this
oh there you are
it's so good to see you i wish i was
there with you but
congratulations on your new show and
boy do you know how to make a splash
what a great success you're having
congratulations
you know i'm desperate for your approval
so
i that actually makes me feel so good
and by the way
did you ever get a a picture i took a
picture of myself next to
the flowers that you and robin sent we
just wanted to send you some flowers to
welcome you to the pool
and you've been so natural and so
authentic so how can it be anything but
a success
that means so much to me
um how and why did you know
back in the day that you are going to
take this approach
like what was as oprah says the aha
moment what was the impetus
for you to create a brand that was so
truth-riddled no-nonsense as well as
helpful
you know there's two things to it uh you
know
i grew up with an alcoholic father and
you know when you grow up with an
alcoholic parent
um and a real passive mother you get
very self-reliant at a very early
age and i was pretty much on my own when
i was 14
and and also being
very very poor i mean i was like what
poor wants to be when it grows up
and when you're very poor you become
very
results-oriented it's like
you can tell when somebody's been really
poor because somebody that's
like sort of poor they'll say you don't
work you don't eat
but somebody that's really poor will say
you don't work
and get paid today you don't eat
and so i've been very results oriented
don't tell me show me do something
change what you're doing don't reward
bad behavior make the right choices
the universe rewards action do something
different if you want something
different
so i just grew up where you know you
just
winners do things losers don't want to
do you just got to get out there and do
it
first of all i didn't realize that you
were basically taking care of yourself
at 14 that's when i got emancipated by
the united states courts and
they were like you are legally an adult
go
but did you have like some steps and
moments when
in your teen years where you're like i
think i know
where i need to head well i did you know
everybody has currency that's different
you know there's monetary currency
social currency emotional currency
spiritual currency
and you know i was very poor
in those school years but for me
there was athletic currency and i was a
i was a fairly good athlete so that
meant i had a peer group
and i could fit in i didn't have the
clothes and i didn't have the shoes i
didn't have the car
and stuff but when you stepped on the
athletic field
that was a real equalizer and so i
learned real early on if you distinguish
yourself then you can
you can become a leader and make your
way through so
that was my currency at the time and so
they got me through junior high high
school and college as an athlete
by the way now that you're on that
mountain top and you've been there for
so many years
do you have any tips for like being five
minutes early or like dead on time
because i'm still trying to master it
i've gotten so much better
i'm like i i'm really like
i i'm so close i can taste it
what is the key to being on time dr phil
there's a lot of research
about people that are chronically late
and
people that are chronically late are
chronically late because
they think they're so important they
can't leave where they are
because the world will fall off its axis
as they do if they do
and they think that time will suspend
for them because they really think the
world revolves around
them and they don't stop and
empathetically think
what does this mean for everybody else
on the other end
i feel like i'm at fault of all of it
like
i'm trying to do too many things i have
too many things on my plate i'm
like i've got my head in the clouds i've
got 80 things going on and 80
plates spinning it's how nice it would
be to show up early and get to just kind
of
sit around and have something to drink
and put your feet up for a minute
that is what baroque says my therapist
i'm not kidding he's like you have to
get there five minutes early
don't be afraid of wasting time
luxuriate
and i'm still like i'm getting better at
being on time i have not
achieved the five minutes earlier but i
will say
there's like a few things i'm i i don't
i will fix it it might take like 40
years but i will fix
it my other question was when you
already know something and you have to
take a step back and get into your sort
of
patient teacher side like i have to do
as a parent i
already know this thing but my child
doesn't what's a good thing for us to
say to ourselves when we have to
stop acting like why aren't you caught
up to where i'm
at and i'm gonna go back and teach you
or guide you or help you or be patient
with you to get to where you need to be
god that is such a smart question i'm so
glad you asked that
particularly right now because we have
so many parents
that are frustrated trying to teach
their kids
yeah because they're doing all this
homeschooling right now that is such a
great and timely question
and i i tell you the thing that i try to
do
is think about the things that frustrate
me trying to figure them out like i can
read really fast and i remember things
really well
that i read but when it comes to like
math
i can't add two and two and get five
every time it just kind of all
runs together and i'm like what is all
of this
and i think about how frustrated and
lost
i feel when i was learning all of that
stuff and i think
that's probably what this looks like to
them right now
the key that i try to get people to
understand
is it's our job to meet them where
they are in their understanding instead
of getting
them to meet us where we are in our
understanding
listen ask them questions tell me what
you understand about the pandemic
what do you understand about coronavirus
what do you understand about the
quarantine
and meet them at that level use their
vocabulary
use their symbol system and all of a
sudden
you'll just link up with them like you
wouldn't believe
and you won't be you won't at all be
frustrated you'll meet them where they
are
it works every single time i am
so glad that i asked i really
am
[Music]